[Music]
all right breaking news tonight about
high-profile mainstream media
journalists who are being accused of
sexual misconduct CBS News has now
suspended lyin of the liberal media
anchor Charlie Rose and PBS is now
stopping production and distribution of
his show following a report in The
Washington Post now according to the
Post tonight eight women are accusing
rose of inappropriate sexual behavior
including by making unwanted sexual
advances lewd phone calls being naked in
front of them and groping them in a
statement to the post Rose admitted
wrongdoing he apologized for his actions
and he said that he thought he was
pursuing shared feelings then there is
New York Times reporter Glen thrush he
has also been suspended tonight over a
vox.com report where several women are
accusing him of sexual misconduct that
includes unwanted sexual contact and
kissing thrush has apologized also in a
statement we're going to continue to
follow both these stories tonight but
the developing situation with Senator Al
Franken and the latest comments from
Hillary Clinton
it is now exposing a massive problem
with the liberal mainstream media in
America because for decades the media
has been feigning moral outrage when it
comes to allegations against Republicans
while defending year in and year out
those Democrats who have been accused of
doing far worse a massive double
standard and tonight there is a new
allegation against Franken a second
woman is now accusing Democratic senator
al franken of sexual misconduct
the woman is alleging that during a 2010
State Fair in Minnesota senator Franken
grabbed her behind all the two were
posing for a picture the woman also
posted the picture on Facebook and later
responded to a comment about this
writing quote Al Franken totally
molested me creeper now keep in mind
this is two years into frankenz first
term as a u.s. senator now senator
Franken is responding to the latest
allegations by saying well he takes
thousands of pictures with the people he
doesn't remember this specific incident
and Senator groper added that he feels
badly that the woman felt disrespected
by their interaction now we did reach
out to Senator Franken for a statement
but his office shockingly refuses to get
back to us unfortunately none of this
should really be all that
surprising this is the same guy who made
jokes nobody else in the media will talk
about it about drugging and raping women
joke who does this and last week
Franklin was accused of sexual
misconduct by radio host Lee aunt Whedon
and tweetIn revealed explosive
information about Senator Franken last
week according to her during a 2006 USO
tour Franken forcibly kissed her while
supposedly rehearsing a skit backstage
there's also this photo of Franken
gropin tweeting while she was asleep on
a flight now Leanne tweetIn says she
didn't even know that happened until
after she got home and started looking
through pictures of that trip Franken
did issue an apology but claims he
doesn't remember the kissing incident
backstage senator Franken is also being
accused of harassing yet another woman
Melanie Morgan radio TV personality
co-founder of the website media
equalizer she's accusing Franken of
harassing her on the phone this
allegedly happened after they got into
an on-air argument during an appearance
on Bill Maher's old show politically
incorrect back in 2000 and Melanie
Morgan says she had to threaten to call
the police to get franken to stop which
he did now despite all of that some
members of the media well they're making
excuses for Al Franken even tonight take
a look there's a new report that senator
Al Franken grabbed a women a woman's
behind at a fair back in 2010 he says he
doesn't remember doing it we're gonna
start to go after everyone in every
power industry for something like a butt
slap I'm worried that there's gonna be
no one left running anything yeah that
may be true ask him to resign I don't
know if that's the appropriate response
either I mean no senator has been asked
to resign ever with all so I think
unfortunately slowly slid culturally
into the into a moment when forgiveness
is now married to ideology if you're a
conservative and you know Bill Clinton
you know Al Franken get him out there
get her right he fought it took a
picture which his office now says was a
joke that showed him potentially not
actually groping but mock groping her
she also published a
that was given to her of her asleep with
senator franken mock groping her excuse
me in the case of Lee aunt Whedon
there's the evidence it's all there
franken's not even denying it it just
shows how low the mainstream media
Democrats are willing to go to defend
people that suit their ideology like
Franken and what the mainstream media
won't tell you is that Franken has been
sick and twisted for years for example
he was on Saturday Night Live 1995 he
suggested a skit about drugging and
raping Lesley Stahl of 60 minutes he
said quote well I give the pills to
Lesley Stahl then when Leslie's passed
out I take her to the closet and rape
her or that's why you never see Leslie
until February when she passes out I put
her in various positions and take
pictures of her it's creepy supposed to
be funny and in 2000 Franken he wrote a
satirical article for Playboy magazine
the headline porn arama
the vast majority what Franken wrote we
can't even repeat on TV but in one part
Franken wrote quote I'm talking of
course about the Internet which is a
terrific learning tool for example a
couple of years ago when he was 12 my
son he used the internet for a sixth
grade report on bestiality then in 2008
when Franklin was running for the Senate
he actually apologized for the comments
we just showed you but it turns out
Franklin was lying how do we know
because in his new book Franken says he
faked the apologies in order to win
votes
he writes quote to say I was sorry for
writing a joke was to sell out my career
to sell out who I'd bet my entire life
and I wasn't sorry what I had written
porn Arama or pitched that stupid lesley
stahl joke at 2:00 in the morning I was
just doing my job
oh his apologies aren't real then
there's the Clintons now for those of
you in the mainstream media pay
attention why is this important because
for 30 years 30 Democrats on behalf of
the Clintons have smeared slandered
besmirched victim shamed anyone and
everyone who dared to tell what turned
out to be the truth about Bill Clinton
and the media has always been there
willing accomplices in and out this they
have been complicit up to and including
through last year the only reason now
someone
political world or finally - starting to
acknowledge what Clinton did is because
Bill and Hillary Clinton are no longer
important so now that it's politically
expedient how that they can't hurt them
the Clintons that is all members of the
media even some but only some are only
beginning to start to call out the
deplorable behavior so it's not about
principle for them it's about well from
1991 until 2016 the media defends the
Clintons on everything regardless of how
damaging or disgraceful the allegations
were and well they can do it now they
can say well maybe it wasn't right I
believe Juanita
okay well Hillary Clinton continues to
smear slander besmirched our husbands
accuser today just take a listen the
latest attack by Hillary look I think
every situation has to be judged on its
own merits I think it's unfortunate that
people are either misremembering or
misinterpreting history really every one
of those woman women they're miss Murray
remembering Hillary well what happened
to believing as Hillary told us in an
election year women when they do come
forward remember this today I want to
send a message to every survivor of
sexual assault
don't let anyone silence your voice you
have the right to be heard you have the
right to be believed and we're with you
right to be believed you're with them as
Hillary Clinton really think that the
women who have accused her husband of
sexual misconduct and even rape that
aren't there actually miss remembering
what Bill did to them
Hillary herself orchestrated a campaign
to discredit and destroy all of them and
here's what the media said about the
Clintons accusers just last year during
the election take a look the rape
accusation is decades old and
discredited only in the sort of the mind
of some sort of movie writer of a third
world democracy if our dictatorship
would you have a candidate for publicly
humiliate a former occupant of that
office by parading all of all of these
other people around as well it's Hillary
Clinton who is the candidate here not
Bill Clinton
she was not implicated in any misconduct
she was not someone who was accused even
of doing anything untoward with regard
to these women pretty despicable now
fast forward one year 2017
despite this come-to-jesus moment from
some on the left while some are still
today Clinton sympathizers in the press
and the Democratic Party they'll never
give it up what's this he more than paid
the price for what what he did the mere
fact that he went through an impeachment
process as president means that there
will always be a shadow on the legacy of
his presidency so at least from my point
of view I think he's more than paid the
price he didn't get away with anything
okay he was investigated it was
litigated he was impeached he had
finally after lying about the affair
admitted it apologized multiple times in
a very heartfelt way that's one of the
many allegations against those
allegations Paula Jones there's yes
flowers this one India Broderick there's
Kathleen Willey there's a bunch all of
which were investigated litigated
adjudicated we got a new left wing
talking point the bill clinton paid the
price for his sins
now the Clintons treated bills accusers
horribly systematically did everything
they could do to publicly shame them and
smear them and slander them in 92 during
the presidential primaries gennifer
flowers revealed she had a 12-year
affair with Bill Clinton
the Clinton campaign remember they had a
war room bimbo eruptions they sprung
into action all to attack flowers and
then Bill and Hillary they show up on 60
minutes they deny the charges and when
after flowers character and the media
they never took it seriously how do we
know take a look at this clip from the
documentary the war room it shows how
the press the liberal media in this
country actually reacted to a question
during that flowers press conference
watch them laugh
just in town he told me to just deny it
governor could use a condom
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen ladies and
gentlemen we're gonna put this to stop
if there any further questions that are
degrading in my opinion library that's
the media laughing what'd they find so
funny now to further smear Flowers
Hillary told Vanity Fair the following
well if we've been in front of a jury
I'd say miss flowers isn't it true you
were asked by the AP in June of 1990 you
said no weren't you asked by the
Arkansas Democrat and you said no I mean
I would crucify her really Hillary
crucify her what happened to believing
her
women have a right to be believed then
in Carl Bernstein's book about Hillary's
while he writes that Clinton would refer
to Jennifer flowers as trailer trash
Bill Clinton later admitted to having a
sexual relationship with flowers and he
admitted it only when he was under oath
next up Paula Jones she accused Bill
Clinton of exposing himself in a hotel
room and after filing a lawsuit against
them on Clinton ended up paying Jones
eight hundred fifty thousand dollars
with an out-of-court settlement and in a
related case Clinton lost his law
license in Arkansas for five years the
Clinton machine also went vicious after
Jones according to the New York Times in
fake news CNN and other outlets longtime
Clinton ally
CNN pundit for a while James Carville
remember infinim infamously said this
about Jones if you drag a hundred-dollar
bill to a trailer park you never know
what you'll find
and Carville also slammed Jones by
saying the she only sued Clinton because
of money then of course there's Monica
Lewinsky the White House intern that had
an affair with Bill Clinton and just
like the other accusers well Hillary had
a nasty nickname for Lewinsky according
to a journal entry that was made public
Hillary's friend Diane Blair said
Hillary called Lewinsky a quote
narcissistic loony - and you have
Kathleen Willey she accused Bill Clinton
in the Oval Office Oh Grob groping and
grabbing and fondling and touching and
kissing her all against her will while
she was a volunteer at the White House
well Willy later said that Hillary
enabled her husband's predatory behavior
and of course we can't forget Juanita
Broderick she alleged that Bill Clinton
raped her in 1978 Broderick also
describes an encounter where Hillary
tried to silence her well that's who the
Clintons
are who they've always been what they
did to these women is reprehensible
Clinton's 1992 presidential campaign
came up with the term bimbo eruptions to
describe the women who came forward and
made accusations against Bill now George
Stephanopoulos wrote in his memoir that
in 91 Hillary said quote we have to
destroy her when describing one of bills
accusers and speaking of George I'll
watch how he handled one person who
threatened to leak information about
Bill Clinton to the press watch this
what his name suggests I can send you a
fax with names addresses phone numbers
of who you had an affair with it
wouldn't make it true
it is completely if you went on the
radio and said that blew Clinton is the
father of illegitimate black child you
would be laughed at people would think
you're crazy I guarantee you that if you
do this you'll never work in democratic
politics again maybe you don't want to
I'm not saying it matters you will be
embarrassed before the national press
corps people will think nobody will
believe you
and people will think you're scum that
the alternative is you don't do it it
causes you some temporary pain with
people who tomorrow aren't going to
matter and you have a campaign that
understands it in a difficult time you
did something right and you know that's
important I mean it doesn't mean
anything we can't do anything for you
specifically or anything like that but
you you know that you did the right
thing yeah good morning America you'll
never work again you'll be embarrassed
too blah blah blah this is how the
Clintons are this is who they've been
for 30 years that our allies in the
Democratic Party their friends in the
media they knew it they did everything
they could to cover it up and completely
trash Bill's accusers up to and
including last year's election is that
inexcusable media also never reported
that Hillary and a family foundation I
talked about it a lot yet last year took
tens of millions of dollars from
countries that abuse women kill gays and
lesbians persecute Christians and Jews
which is horrible she took all that
money the clip
is literally by taking it endorse that
repressive behaviors they bought her
silence and the media of course all last
year they gave him a free pass now so
while it's nice to see that some on the
left and in the media well now that the
Clintons have no power are only starting
to admit how horrible the Clintons were
to build as accusers I argue it's a
little too little too late here with
reaction